let's get into audience questions for
the week here's the first one hey David
you've mentioned before that even though
you support rank-choice voting that
there are other systems that you think
might be better which systems would you
prefer to rank the choice so there's a
couple of issues with ranked choice one
of them is that there are arguments that
it might violate the idea of one-person
one-vote because in rank choice voting
when you rank the candidates there's
sort of an initial round of voting
that's done and then on that basis and
depending on whether your number one
choice is viable there is a second round
during which your vote is moved to
somebody else and there are opponents of
rank choice who say that's kind of two
votes you're voting twice within one
election and it violate violates one
person one vote there are some other
systems that I think are interesting
there's one called Condorcet type voting
rules and those are ones where voters
rank candidates in order of choice and
each candidate is compared with the
others in terms of how many voters rank
one ahead of the other so for example if
there's a candidate that beats everybody
else in all of the comparisons right if
candidate a beats candidate B candidate
a beats candidate C beats D so on and so
forth that candidate clearly has won if
there isn't then you need some
contingent way of selecting so in other
words if candidate a beats candidate B
but B beats C and C beats a for
hypothetically right I don't know but
but they're ranked in different ways you
would need some subsequent system to
sort of rank it's kind of like it's not
really like the World Cup but it's sort
of like okay well who has the most
points in the group and if they have the
same number of points actually that's
not really a good example whatsoever but
I think I think people sort of get the
idea right and the problem with these
types of rules in normal rank-choice
voting when you don't have some
subsequent system is that a candidate
can end up winning without being
anybody's first choice so you could have
a situation in normal rank choice voting
where candidate a ends up with twelve
percent of the vote in the first
around but somebody else had six so
candidate a makes it to the second round
and in the second round candidate a ends
up with 32 percent of the vote and
they've still not received the plurality
but it's enough to go to the next round
and therefore you can end up with the
candidate winning who was it anybody's
actual first choice on the basis of
being a plurality of voters second third
or fourth choice or something like that
that does seem like a problem with rank
choice voting doesn't it yeah I like
this thought experiment I think it's
just getting so overly complex right I
mean ranked choice voting voting is
already tough enough to explain to some
people yes and it's though it's hard to
push for dorset anything else yeah and
even more complex and the other problem
with the Condorcet type rules is that
number one it's very logistical ii
difficult to count in large elections
and also you need people to agree as to
what the subsequent method would be for
ranking so to answer the question I
don't actually know specifically what
type of method I would prefer to normal
ranked choice but I recognize that there
is a problem where it doesn't seem
democratic where a candidate that isn't
anybody's first choice ends up being the
winning candidate that seems
fundamentally wrong to me and I don't
actually have the answer yeah and the
one-person one-vote thing is a problem
with the ranked choice voting to Inc -
but you also see that with the electoral
college right
yeah that's why ideally we would get rid
of that and replace it with the popular
vote maybe the states could have the
option to put in ranked choice voting as
at the individual level yeah and we're
already seeing by the way that states
making those efforts including Maine are
meeting with pretty significant
opposition when it actually comes to
enacted so I'm actually it's just an
open question I'm comfortable telling
you that I'm not totally sure I've
identified not that I've come up with it
but I've read quite a bit about the
problems with normal ranked choice
voting but I've not yet sort of taken a
strong position as to which system I
would prefer